PROFESSOR: Our
method for estimating
sums can also be used to
estimate products, basically
by taking logs to turn
a product into a sum.
And we're going to
use that to come up
with another important
estimate of a quantity that
will come up, really, very
regularly called n factorial.
S n factorial is the product of
the first n integers, 1 times
2 up through n minus 1 times n.
In concise product
notation, it's
the product-- that's pi,
capital pi, for product-- from i
equals 1 to n of i.
And its standard abbreviation
is to write it as n!
pronounced n factorial.
So what I'd like to do is
get an asymptotic estimate
for n factorial.
Again, n factorial is one
of these quantities where
there isn't any exact
formula that doesn't
have those ellipses in it.
There's no short formula
with basic operations
fixed size of formula that
expresses n factorial.
But we get a nice formula for
a tight asymptotic estimate.
So as I said, the first trick is
to turn the product into a sum
by taking logs.
So log of n factorial is the
log of 1-- the product of 1
through n.
But a log of a product
is the sum of the logs,
so it's simply log of 1 plus
log of 2 up through log of n.
And expressed in
sum notation, it's
the sum from i equals
1 to n of log of i.
Now, the integral
method gives us
a way to estimate this
sum by bracketing it
between the values
of some integrals,
namely restating the
integral method for sum--
for bounding integrals by sums.
This time, we're looking
at an increasing function
because it's log of x.
Let f be a weakly increasing
function from positive reals
the positive reals.
I'm interested in the sum from
i equals 1 to n of f of i.
And I want to relate it and
bound it by the integral
from 0-- from 1 to n of f
of x where, in this case,
the particular f that
we're interested in
is f of x is log x.
And the theorem says that
with increasing functions
s is bracketed between the
integral plus the last term
in the sum and the integral
plus the first term in the sum.
Remember, since the function
is weakly increasing, f of 1
is smaller than f of n.
So that's the way you remember
which way the bounds go.
So s is between I plus
f of 1 and I plus f of n
by our general formula for
applying integral bounds
to sums.
Well, what that tells us then
is that the sum from 1 to n
of log of i, which is
what we're interested in,
is bracketed between
the integral from 1 to n
of log x and the integral from
1-- well, it's plus log of 0,
but-- log of 1
rather, but that's 0.
And the integral from 1 to n
of log of x plus the last term,
which is log of n.
In case you don't remember
from first term calculus,
the integral of log
of x is, in fact--
has the indefinite integral
is x log of x over e,
which you can easily check by
differentiating x log x over e.
ln means natural log, remember.
In computer science, L-O-G,
log means log to the base 2
unless you explicitly
put some base on it
like log, L-O-G, sub 10.
So ln is the natural
log from calculus.
And plugging in this value for
the indefinite integral of log
of x and using the bounds
1, n, what we come up
with is that the sum of the logs
is bounded between n times log
n over e and n times log
n over e plus log of n.
It's a pretty tight bounds.
What that means is that
informally speaking,
the sum of the logs is about
this term plus that term.
Plus, let's take the average
value of that term, which
is half this term.
So we could say that the sum
of logs is approximately equal.
That's a little vague,
but live with it.
n log n over e
plus half of log n.
Well, now, if I'm
interested, remember,
in an estimate for
n factorial-- so
let's exponentiate both sides.
So taking e to this sum
gives me a product of e
to this times e to that.
Well, e to this is-- really,
it's e to the log of n over e
to the nth power, which
means it's n over e to the n.
And this is e to the log
of n to the power half,
or square root of n.
So we wind up with
n factorial is
approximately equal to the
square root of n times n over e
to the n.
Now, this approximately
equal is imprecise.
It's not asymptotically
equal because we
were doing an arithmetic
average of 0 and log n over 2.
In addition, it's
very dangerous when
you have two things
that are approximately
equal to exponentiate them
and expect that they're still
approximately equal.
Often, they aren't.
But nevertheless, this is a
kind of a heuristic derivation
of some kind of
asymptotic estimate
that we would expect that
n factorial was roughly
like the square root of n times
n over e to the nth power.
And it turns out that it's--
that this heuristic gives
a pretty accurate answer.
A precise approximation is
that n factorial is actually
asymptotically equal to the
square root of 2 pi n times
n over e to the n.
And we're not going
to prove that.
It requires elementary
calculus, but more than we
want to take time for.
And this crucial formula that
we will be using very regularly
to estimate the
size of n factorial
is called Stirling's
Formula, and it's
one to have on your crib sheets
if you haven't memorized it.